what do you believe in said the Quran is
the message from God I believe in it you
believe that the messenger muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam is the
Messenger of God said yes I do and then
our son said ok repeat after me
ashhadu an LA ilaha illallah so he
repeated after him
he said his Shahada I was like wow this
is this is amazing like if somebody told
me this three four years ago I would
have said I know where he's he's an 80s
[Music]
bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings a peace walk to the day show
how you guys doing I have an incredible
guest incredible story a man who was
living without purpose but was seeking
purpose and he's found purpose and he's
here and I'm here with them guess we're
in Bosnia this is our brothers like how
are you Salam alaikum like very good who
are you hamdulillah you have an
incredible story and it's very unique
how Allah the Creator the heavens are
earth answers das please share with us
this unique experience how it happened
how it brought us here where we're here
together today yes that was the cause of
the of the door exactly that God is here
sitting now together there was
approximately 5 years ago when me and my
very good friend started researching
about a lot of stuff and that's how we
how he came to Islam and started
researching about Islam we were born
Muslims but never never practiced Islam
so we started research doing research
research research for about 2 years and
suddenly Allah just gave us opened our
hearts and our mind that this is this is
the way of life this is this is our
purpose of life and so during that
research as we just opened our minds my
friend said ok you you realize now we
gotta establish prayer because this this
is the main pillar
everything of being a Muslim I was
looking I'm like yeah yes we have we
have to we have to establish prayer but
I don't know how I never prayed I never
in my life before I didn't know how to
take we do nothing and he typed in new
tube he typed how to pray just how to
pray found a good video I gave it to me
here
take a look at this you can learn from
this that's a great video I looked at it
you can you can it's explained voodoo
and the prayer okay I typed it in how to
pray and it started with the Dean show I
had no idea what the Dean show is you
came up I had no idea who you are
nothing okay so for a couple of days I
was looking at learning from that video
how to establish prayer also learning a
al-fatiha because I had no idea about
anything and in in those couple of days
when I was looking at it and started
establishing prayer in my own eyes it
was like God dois that I made having no
idea who you are and everything I would
love to meet this guy he he taught me
how to establish prayer but that that's
all that's just crossed my mind I had no
idea as I said who you are what the Dean
show is nothing so about one year has
passed since from that I was sitting
with that friend of mine were sitting in
in a coffee shop in here at best Russia
and across there's a mosque and he saw a
man walking in there I didn't know the
man he he knew him he saw him and we
didn't even know your Bosnian roots this
is Eddie's father so now you see my
father growing in the mosque you and not
me my friend I didn't even know no Hasan
this is that his father Eddie well the
guy from the Dean show and coffee
started watching a little bit the Dean
show he's like yeah that's his father
I'm walking man I gotta meet this guy I
gotta I gotta go approach him so I went
the the next man the next time of Salah
was I went to the mosque he was there
again after the Salah waited outside and
I approached him so we had a sit down
had a coffee we're very good friends
meanwhile because it comes often here to
Surya
so we talked about told him my story and
everything and how I wanted to meet you
and every thought when when we first
start together he told me that you guys
live in Chicago
and my advice brother lives in Chicago
and that's great like okay no
coincidence at all and then after that
think next year we went to Chicago me
and my wife and my kid and the place
where your brother lives is as you as
you know ten minutes walking distance
from from your place
so in that's huge in that huge city of
Chicago also coincidence no way that's
that's the plan of Allah he answered my
dua that is amazing amazing amazing
we're here in Bosnia and Bosna comes to
dobro cooks 300 that so what happened
before your before you start to look
search and see what was going on in your
life because many people you're fairly
young they're not thinking about this
thing that we're talking about now about
you know worshipping the Creator not the
creation in establishing prayer you know
living Islam you know many people are
involved in so many different things so
many things distracting them young kids
nightclubs chasing girls chasing boys
you know fashion entertainment video
games doing everything but opposite of
seeking why am I here in this life
what's my purpose what happened in your
life so people can relate that started
to have you think like beyond the
materialism in the material world okay
what happened before I was one of these
people that you just mentioned I used to
I used to own a nightclub here in Surrey
ever not from from not far from here and
I owned it for four years three or four
years and this is this is an awful
business there's alcohol there's there's
many many many bad things and that
that's what was going on in my life
doing the these years so me and my
friend that I mentioned before we were
hanging out at that club I used to have
an apartment right above so we're
hanging out there we go to my
that's where we did the research on one
computer typed in a lot of things
research research but it started when we
started thinking okay what is what is
this what is this purpose all these
troubles when you own a nightclub
there's many many troubles coming along
with that different kind of troubles so
there's there's no peace in your life
and that that's what got us thinking
what was the purpose of life and that's
when we started also researching about
Islam what is because we were as I said
born Muslims so but not practicing you
know primarily your father mother more
like Anna communist atheist yes my
father mostly my mother but also no
practicing not know purchasing nothing
nothing no you wanted to know what what
what you you obviously believe there's a
creator I did alhamdulillah I always
believe there's a creator and I always
believed in the revelation Quran but I
know I never even took the translation
to read the Quran nothing that was like
okay I believe but now I realize there's
you can't just say okay I believe and
that's it
you go that's not our purpose so now did
you put the crown to the test yes yeah
yes first okay then let me started
researching researching researching
after a while we said okay let's see
what the Quran says let's see the
translations we didn't even we didn't
start praying yet okay we started
reading the translation and at the
beginning when what I was all these
years all these troubles with the
nightclub and everything all the stress
in life and I came right at the
beginning when I started reading the
Quran there's a verse about Jenna about
Jenna and the description of Jenna
the forever lasting peace I was like oh
that's it that's what I'm looking for
the forever lasting peace there's no
trouble there's forever because you got
an any club now but you don't have that
what you're looking for that no no I
said constant trouble yes stress
concentration I want to get away
this I want to get away from this I
always like I don't want this in my life
but there's no other way okay that's
that's what I got that's why I got now
and then I said so that read that in the
Quran about Jenna that's what got me
like okay this is it
this is what I want how do I get this
and that's when you realize you can't
just say I believe in God I believe the
Quran is the relation of God and that's
it I don't want to practice that what's
the point of the revelation what's the
point of God sending the messenger
sallallahu alayhe wassallam what's the
point
23 years he was the messenger what's the
point of all that if I'm gonna say okay
I believe but I don't want this am i
disregard ya just regard it what's the
point of all this and that's how you how
you get to me when I saw that the that's
what Mo's got me and the everlasting
peace no trouble no stress no nothin
that's in Jannah and okay I want this
how do I achieve this and that is true
following the message following the
Quran following the Sunnah and staying
away from what Allah has prohibited and
also I just what I needed to say to say
okay this is the revelation there is no
dog this is the relation revelation from
God the Quran okay let's see
scientifically what they say about the
Quran and when I saw that all these
numberless I would say examples examples
and and evidence of scientific evidence
that 1400 years ago people had no way no
way of knowing it like the the baby when
it starts yeah the developing that's all
explained that people maybe maybe
hundred years ago yeah
scientifically when it was proven proven
50 hundred years ago people 1,400 years
somebody knew that and people say okay
he could have somehow know it
okay no way something that just was
recently discovered now this is being
discussed 1400 years ago yeah yeah yeah
it's not possible it's one example out
of hundred and more yeah
and that's when I saw scientific proof
that the Quran is from God because
there's no way people and what's the
point even okay some people say okay he
could have known that what's the point
of saying it's from God why didn't he
claim it from itself yeah yeah
why don't you claim it from your sermon
you have such a knowledge
why don't you claim it for yourself why
do you say it's from God if it's if it's
not so the but again there's no way
people could have known these things
fourteen hundred years ago and that
that's the beautiful thing I like what
you said like all of the emphasis that
the last the final messenger who's a
brother to Jesus Moses Abraham he was
just a seal of the prophets he kept on
emphasizing worship the Creator worship
the Creator love liberation nothing with
himself don't know him he said don't
idolize me don't worship just the
Creator that's what you that's amazing
what you just said all emphasis is on
God yes I don't want as he said
sallallahu alayhe wassallam I don't want
nothing from this from you people
I don't expect expect anything just
worship the Creator the one and only and
and that's something that's amazing the
message the simplicity of Islam
submission to the will of the creator
not the creation is the pure monotheism
tutto he that just worship the one who
created you you guys can understand that
it's simple no Trinity no worshipping a
man a stick a stone a bone a human being
Jesus nobody but the one who created
Jesus the one who created this whole
universe and everything in it God
Almighty in Arabic and that's the only
thing that makes sense that makes
there's one God just one who created
everything that that's the only thing
that made sense to me yes I also took a
little bit to admit I didn't go into the
whole thing about Christianity but I did
research it on the beginning also okay
let's see what what what's this this is
all about and a lot lot lot of things
make no sense
specially the Trinity like there's one
God one entry God came down to earth God
God got killed
to that we get our sins forgiven that
just didn't make sense doesn't make
sense the innate disposition of the
human being it accepts doesn't reject
the message of Islam the the belief
system is of Islam if a person is open
you are definitely open you were seeking
you were since yes luckily and inside
yourself were you earnestly asking the
Creator because that's what we usually
tell people start within yourself
because if your heart is open and if you
want to receive if you want the truth
and you seek the truth seek it and
you'll find it so you were seeking of
course yourself also what I would like
to mention it's a thing that I it's
constantly in my mind even as I said
before alhamdulillah I always believed
in God there was like never for me a
question if there's a God so even before
in that chaotic life of mine little
things like when I would take a shower I
had a nice apartment nice shower and
before way before years before Islam I
would like I was feeling good and I
would sometimes thank God thank you God
that I have this nice apartment I can
have this nice shower
it was just in my mind a couple of times
and maybe also this is a huge thing
knowing that everything you have is from
God and thanking thank thank Allah
whatever he gave you and this may also
have been a trigger to to you know that
Allah Allah had mercy on me
to guide me towards the truth that is a
very important point you hear that take
notes right here little things you can
do we talk about being sincere being
genuine wanting to truth because if you
don't want it I mean it's not gonna be
open you're not gonna see it but if you
want to and then what he was saying
being grateful and thankful is just
common sense that design indicates the
designer and thanking the one for little
things he was doing
thank being grateful and thankful and
then door just started open up my next
question is amazing
tell us the story what happens next with
your father
okay and that there is also that that's
a story that really really makes me
happy because as you said at the
beginning
my father was weird here way years
before communism here in Bosnia so
people would raise their the people
would follow that idea about communism
communism the whole idea there is no god
there's no creator and my father was
raised like that he was an atheist he
didn't believe in God so when I accepted
Islam started practicing I thought about
this ok my father he doesn't believe in
God and two years two and a half years
ago he was here in Sarajevo he doesn't
live here now he was here in Syria
visiting and he had a little heart
problem when he was visiting so he ended
up in the hospital nothing serious or
hamdulillah but he ended up in the
hospital so he was there for like 10
days I visited him every day and when he
got out I decided ok I'm gonna use this
opportunity to start talking to him
about the creator first so event I asked
him okay let's go for breakfast is ok we
went for breakfast and when we sat down
I was like right away ok what how do you
feel about God he smiled
I was I was afraid he's gonna say ok
don't bother me with that stuff you know
my opinion about this don't bother me
but still I went I asked him so he
smiled his and he said you know how I
feel about it
did I doubt there's a God so
alhamdulillah he he did wanted to talk
about it he didn't he didn't refuse he
didn't run away or anything so he sat
there for three to four hours talking
talking talking talking and the whole
idea I was approaching to him is like
there's no sense he's he's a smart guy
he also knows knows the stuff knows
about science knows a little bit how the
universe works and he said all these the
the planets that the distance from the
earth to the Sun it was it was it would
be a little bit closer a little bit
further away we wouldn't exist here the
earth wouldn't exist and that's all
these examples he took and that that got
him to think about it there's no way
this can function without the Creator
who keeps this whole thing going you
mentioned something very important to
fine-tuning everything is in its proper
place
everything collapse exactly yeah and
that's that's what got him also like the
the main thing I think I mean main thing
that God came thinking accepting that
there's a creator is that everything is
in its place
somebody has to care take care of this
and now what happens next now so you
have a he's coming to visit you you're
talking you're being you know real
respect for what your father and he's
like and is he liking the change that's
happy does he see something different in
you like definitely definitely
even before I started talking to him he
saw he he knew I was started practicing
Islam and he saw the change
definitely definitely he's like I'm very
very happy how you are now the way you
used to be liked it it's a huge
difference alhamdulillah it's a huge
difference you just have to change when
you start as I said before doing what
what the Creator told you to do and
staying away what he forbade you to do
you become a different a better the
better much much better person yeah
that's what he saw that by itself if
parents knew the rights that they have
and how children are supposed to treat
their parents with kindness and
gentleness in a day and age nowadays
where children are you know giving their
just had to say their parents the middle
finger rehearsing there no respect
yeah but that's a thing they'll lead you
a straight one way ticket to the
Hellfire being like that towards your
parents but Islam honors the parent you
know old folks homes and you dump them
and you forget about luckily that's also
one thing about among many that I have
changed like my my treatment toward my
parents my father and my mother so he
sees that now the logical arguments of
design for the universe and he accepts
that what happens next what happens next
is I start talking to him okay
now you realize there's a creator that
Creator who created us who gave us life
who put us on the earth doesn't it make
sense that he gave us a message why are
we here who we are what what are we
doing here what's our purpose here so we
started talking in that direction that
also took about one year me talking to
him and just take it some time it's not
overnight this is like so now Korra left
this and now yeah we left he took me one
year to talk to him to him to realize
there's a creator a she's now of course
patients we always talk patiently and
another year has passed it was in three
months ago just right before Ramadan it
happened that my father was here at the
same time Hasan your father was here so
I I also talked to Hasan about my father
and I'm talking to him and it happened
for them both to be here at the same
time so I called up Hasan and my father
we had to sit together first we had a
coffee and then with short coffee and
then we said okay let's go tomorrow for
breakfast
so he went tomorrow for breakfast and
Hasan also talked to him and I was also
he is they're about the same age so it's
he I think he's gonna take him more
seriously and so we talked there also
for like two or three hours and her son
talked more did the most of the talking
the suddenly he said as they were
talking like he said yes yes yes that's
it
and I'm like what that's it that's it it
is I believe that I believe in it
so what do you believe in said the Quran
is the message from God I believe in it
you believe that the messenger muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam is the
Messenger of God said yes I do and then
our son said ok repeat after me
ashhadu an la illaha IL allah so he
repeated after him he said his Shahada
I was like wow this is this is amazing
like if somebody told me this 3 4 years
ago I would have said I know where he's
he's an atheist no communist raised no
way so I'm looking at him he's repeating
after her son his history hada ash hadu
an LA ilaha illallah there is no other
god but one I was like this is amazing
so he asked me write it down on a piece
of paper because he didn't know I wrote
it down on a piece of paper and he was
visiting here also about three weeks ago
and he showed me from his wallet because
like look at this I still got that piece
of paper I was like I was so grateful
alhamdulillah he started reading the
Quran the translation he told me his
half way through it and inshallah he
also said as I get through it I will get
towards establishing the prayer amazing
amazing amazing so another that people
perceive something it's not no waste
coincidence Allah setting things up now
you're again speaking for your dad and
now it just happens that your dad and my
dad end up inside out having a meeting
and finally after sometime reflection he
figures out man this is the truth he
accepts it and you met the Shahada is he
said there's nothing worthy of worship I
mean this is something the main message
you can dig this you can dig Islam but
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens
earth that's it and he sent messengers
in the last of them including Jesus
Moses Abraham and all the preceding ones
that came last was Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him that
makes sense he accepted it I'll come
back this is a story I tell you give us
now we're closing up but for those
people who are also they're tuning in
you know they might have been doing some
late night reflection like you you are a
former owner of a nightclub you were
running the show and now some people are
watching the Dean show and they're like
you know dealing with that anxiety the
void in the heart
drugs alcohol you know and all the other
chaos that comes of life but they tuned
in what advice do you give for people
who are still stuck in that bubble of
confusion get away from this as as soon
as possible because there is no
happiness there's no happiness in that
kind of lifestyle maybe maybe maybe some
currently when you get like take drugs
drink alcohol passes away two-three
hours you think you feel good but I know
you don't feel good it's just you think
you trick yourself that you feel good
but there is no there's no happiness in
such a lifestyle I know I'm talking from
my own example it's I can't even compare
my life before in my life now how
alhamdulillah how I'm satisfied with my
life I'm happy in my life there's
everybody has some problems you can't
it's dunya it's it's the life here you
can't live without problems but it's not
even comparable to the problem side
before that is amazing thank you so much
what an incredible story insha'Allah
could be a much benefit people watching
just uncle I have some only aleikum
stuff and I want to thank you guys we'll
be out here in Bosnia broadcasting you
can have a look amazing city going back
to the roots over here you know so make
sure you're tuning in so you can see
more about Nia and these incredible
stories that we have coming for you
inshallah
assalamu alaikum peace be with you
[Music]